in 2007 Joel and Ethan Coen released No
Country for Old Men it quickly became
established as one of their greatest
films but it's ambiguous final scene
confuses audiences to this day so let's
journey back to Texas in 1980 and delve
into the ending of No Country for Old
Men the primary narrative of the film
has kicked off when the wellin moss
played by Josh Brolin stumbles upon the
aftermath of a shootout and walks away
with a satchel packed full of money the
deadly confrontation involved two major
crime organizations one based in Mexico
and the other in the United States
viewers know the Mexican half of this
drug deal went seriously wrong but it's
clear from the events of the film that
the other side may be worse off by the
time that dust settles the American
organization attempting to buy the drug
says neither the goods they wanted nor
the cash that Llewellyn made off with
then to make matters worse Javier Bardem
s character Anton Chigurh launches a
reign of terror against them that seems
to go all the way to the top and as
anyone who's seen this movie knows you
do not want to be on the wrong side of
Anton Chigurh it's just supposed to be
the old badass thanks to the relentless
sugar No Country for Old Men is a
white-knuckle ride with shootouts in the
street life-or-death decisions based on
the toss of a coin and harrowing scenes
involving a captive bolt pistol that was
meant to be used in slaughterhouses
however along with action and suspense
the film has plenty of introspective
moments and thoughtful themes that give
viewers a lot to think about after the
movie is over much of No Country for Old
Men Paulo sheriff edy Tom Bell played by
Tommy Lee Jones as he becomes
increasingly concerned about his place
in the world as an aging lawman the
deeper Bell gets into the situation
involving moss sugar and the missing
money the more concerned he is about the
future at one point he flat-out says
that he feels overmatched and worries
that the violence around him is
escalating in a way that he can't
contend with by the end of the film Bell
is retired with the sense of law and
order upended by the moss affair which
means someone else has to follow in his
footsteps and become the next Sheriff
whether that's his deputy or someone
else Bell will no doubt have some
standing in his community as a kind of
elder statesman the MacGuffin at the
center of No Country for Old Men is a
case containing more than two million
dollars in cash we watch as the money
changes hands from the drug dealers to
moss and then to the hit man sugar so
what happens to the money after that we
know that a tracking device was placed
in the case from the very beginning to
keep tabs on its whereabouts but Moss
eventually gets rid of
we also know that sugar was still able
to hunt moss down without the tracker
and sugar didn't exactly disappear
quietly even after a massive car
accident and a broken arm he was able to
patch himself up on the spot and simply
walk away will his surviving former
employers track him down or will sugar
make himself disappear if anyone can
manage to hide himself and two million
dollars in plain sight its Anton Chigurh
midway through the film a man in a
mysterious office building hires Woody
Harrelson's character Carson Wells to
seek out boss and get the money back
before sugar gets his hands on it Wells
a savvy contract killer in his own right
is familiar enough with sugar to know
how dangerous he is and smart enough to
try to get the money without directly
involving him unfortunately for Wells
sugar finds him anyway and kills him on
principle if the organization that hired
Wells is still trying to track down
sugar and the money after the film ends
it's easy to imagine that they'll be
sending out other hired killers to see
who can finally bag sugar it's also easy
to imagine him killing every single one
of them without a moment of hesitation
or concern near the end of the film
after he's found lost dead and realized
that the money is gone sheriff Bell
returns home to visit his uncle Ellis a
former lawman living all alone in a
ramshackle house over the course of
their conversation Bell makes it clear
that he feels he can't contend with the
modern class of criminal Ellis responds
with a certain degree of sympathy but
also tells him about a horrific crime
from many decades earlier
well not quite on par with the massive
drug shootout at the beginning of the
film it reminds Belle that violence is
nothing new the world is a dark place
particularly if you devote your life to
fighting on the side of the light Ellis
explains to Belle that it's vanity to
believe that this struggle is new and
unique to him came to uplift commit
ain't no wait no new Bell seems to
concede this point but also feels the
time is right to hang it up the scene is
a perfect encapsulation of the film's
meditation on how violence preys upon
the soul no country for old man is
remembered for a great many things but
perhaps one of the most discussed
moments of the film is its ambiguous
final scene Bell sits at his dining room
table and tells his wife about a dream
he had in the dream he and his father
are riding on horseback through the
night and his father rides past him
silently carrying fire in a horn he
knows his father will be waiting up
ahead having made a fire for them as
bell says in all that dark and all that
cold
the former Sheriff concludes by saying
this he'd be no cook and with that line
both the dream in the film ends leaving
most viewers scratching their heads in
the context of the rest of the movie as
Bell reckons with his place in the world
the dream feels like the conclusion of a
man who knows that death is the next
milestone he's retired from law
enforcement like his late father before
him and so his subconscious is telling
him that the reunion in the afterlife is
imminent but of course spells dream ends
before he joins his father at the fire
which means that he still has some
living left to do check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bells you don't miss
a single one
[Music]